good morning everyone assu said my name
is Jory person and I am the chief
operating officer of Baku that's uh I
think probably the best job in the whole
wide world second to maybe open web
engineer at beaucoup and that's only
because maybe somebody maybe you don't
know exactly what a COO does and
practically speaking it means I do
really important things like approved
book whose sticker budget laughs at Adam
Sontag's puns I pick up after Rick's
robots as I did yesterday and go to
really important business meetings like
that of the beaucoup diorama club it
also means that I run an open-source
software company and which entails
thinking a lot about how to operate
beaucoup so that it operates in service
of our mission which is to move the open
web forward that's kind of an abstract
idea though so to do this part of my job
I ask a lot of operational questions
which is some essentially boiled down to
the same three themes do we have an
objective or goal identified to execute
in service of our mission I asked what
combinations of teams people projects
resources that sort of thing we need in
order to reach our goal and I asked
probably the most important question how
do those entities exchange information
in order to create change and generate
volume and my bet is that you're part of
some open source project or some
organization where you wear and you
probably ask yourself very similar
questions you ask things like what are
the big picture goals you want to reach
and what milestones might you need to
create and hit in order to meet them
maybe you're asking what some of the
dependencies are that you'll need to
manage or major issues you'll need to
close first or what your code review
process should look like or how you
might handle issue tracking or merging
PRS as our projects and goals get bigger
those operational questions get
increasingly difficult to answer
problems that were once really easy to
solve on a small scale become
exponentially more difficult and also a
little bit more abstract we start asking
questions like how do we get more
collaborators on our projects how do we
get more users how do we pay for servers
how do we allocate our time commitments
to maybe work and then maybe also your
open source project how are you going to
handle issues of IP or trademark
infringement as open source developers
we operate in a pretty complex system
and the fact that it's an open one
doesn't necessarily make it any easier
this week at jas comp we've talked
mostly about the technical elements of
software production systems like the
code the architecture but for the
duration of this talk when I'm referring
to systems I'll be focusing on the human
element and humanity is again kind of an
abstract idea so since this is a
JavaScript conference I decided to
create an MVC framework for thinking
about that kind of abstraction if you're
in a position with your project or
company wherein you need to create a
system for humans remember MVC which is
mission value and change it boils down
to this simple philosophy that every
operator in the system a person a team
you know project of protocol whatever
all of those things have the same job to
execute change that creates value and
service of the mission so let's take a
look really quick at what that means
from NPM modules to boku each component
in our open web system was created for
some reason there's some core objective
or some problem is trying to solve an
entity's mission doesn't really change
over time it's the impotence for change
and not the change itself missions
motivate so in designing systems for
humans make sure you can identify the
mission for every person project and
team in your project or organization
value be a harder thing to nail down
generally when we think of value we
think of quantitative things such as
points scored in a game or like dollars
raised for cancer research quantitative
value
tend to be easier to measure and also
names milestones or metrics for success
like getting to version 1 point 0 or
maybe getting 10,000 users but for
humans you need a mix of quantitative
and qualitative value in order to
evaluate your system success qualitative
value is sort of like the intangible
genesee qua that you gain from an effort
that you can't really pinpoint but often
relates to some new knowledge you gained
or some subtle shift in opinion you may
not be quite sure how far it Lance's you
toward your mission but you do know that
it at least moved forward the components
in our ecosystem don't exactly exist in
a vacuum they don't spontaneously become
they don't keep evolving on their own
without some sort of process of change
if we think of the mission as an end
we'd like to see brought about changes
the means we're executing toward that
end and sometimes it's big and sometimes
it's small but either way our system
should always be changing for the whole
system to be effective our components
need to work together harmoniously even
as they're changing but they also exist
inside of cultural political and
technical contexts and those things can
have real competing motivations
sometimes so it's nearly impossible for
one system change and not affect others
it's hard to know where or when all of
those changes are going to end up
manifesting like how a positive change
on the technical spectrum might actually
spark a negative change and the
political our JavaScript community
obviously cares very much about its
direction and wants to see us move
forward our projects are operating more
transparently and collaborated
collaboratively our companies and
organizations are operating in a more
socially responsible way we're paying
more attention now than ever before to
how we address issues of diversity
inclusion and accessibility but complex
systems like ours don't necessarily
scale well
they tend to fail far more consistently
on the human element rather than a
technical I think we can simplify this
from open source engineer to open source
c-suite I think we all have the same job
which is to support the creation and
exchange of value for the JavaScript
community I do this today at Baku
through identifying and executing
organizational change that ensures we're
living our mission and everything we do
and today I'll try to do that a little
bit by sharing what i've learned about
organizational design as a means to help
you create and scale your progress your
project or organization in whatever
forward way suits your goals experience
has taught me that if we give more
thought to how we organize ourselves we
can do more for our projects and for the
open web community using organizational
design principles will be better able to
adapt to change will be better able to
communicate our mission will be better
able to exchange value with one another
and we'll be able to do all of this
together in a more proactive and
coordinated fashion for those of you who
are still not sure exactly why this
matters let's take a look at a case
study because business people love case
studies this is from an article by
michael rogers on the nodejs and medium
blog from earlier this month he writes
in 2012 things were going really well we
had a thriving community solid core
contributions and it was really clear
that we were the fastest growing
ecosystem in the world so in 2012
michael says the system was pretty
efficient all of our cultural technical
and political variables all of the
projects and people were operating
harmoniously and things were going good
the growth and change of the project
ended up signaling a future imbalance of
the system though is around this time
people notice some concerns in the
project with the ownership and we end up
seeing some people note that there are
more there's more value being created
for the political spectrum then there is
along the cultural or technical and
people in the system
failing to act on that we can we cut to
2014 everybody agrees that there's a
problem but now the operators in our
human system don't know how to change
and change it growth and change in the
system is slowing becoming less
efficient to the point that the project
becomes forked and now there's no clear
way for them to generate a value if we
cut to today that system is being
restored our no denial projects are both
joining the node foundation with support
from the Linux Foundation and there are
plans for these projects to reintegrate
that's all happening because a lot of
people recognize the imbalance of the
system and set to the very hard work of
restoring it they were organizing in
designing systems through really formal
channels like that of the node advisory
board the IO technical committee and a
bunch of other informal channels like
you know github and IRC they put in
thousands of hours of work had probably
untold numbers of debates and arguments
and so on and so forth all of which to
restore harmony in our human open web
ecosystem and so on behalf of beaucoup
I'd like to say thank you to those folks
including Chris for doing that because
it's really hard the thing is their
problems are not unique and another post
on the node blog Michael Dolan was a
director and attorney for the
collaborative projects at Linux
Foundation said that they found that the
challenges of node and i/o communities
are not unique many of the open source
projects that they have also struggle
with the same challenges and went on to
these lists five key features of an open
collaboration project it's clear that
the node foundation is going to be
relying on and learning a lot from this
and there's lots of early indication
that they're going to end up being very
successful with this but an open
governance model doesn't necessarily
guarantee success or growth I think
that's because openness is a soul ideal
is really tricky to nail down the
rhetoric of openness is to meant to
communicate a favorable set of values
and those values often depend on the
speaker and on the audience and the absa
of a single definition that suits all of
those parties we tend to take open to
mean inclusive of everything so if we
want to be successful with our open
collaboration projects we're going to
have to get more specific about our
ideals and our values thoughtful
organizational design helps us balance
the fear of chaos and the fear of
structure inherent in an open system so
that the whole thing can move forward
it's a combination of abstract
philosophy like why we're even here and
what's the meaning of life that kind of
philosophy and concrete structures to
help we humans do things together more
effectively or perhaps put in terms of
the MVC model of earlier it helps us
frame our decisions about change and
value in terms of our mission but I've
certainly talked about abstractions long
enough so it's time to get a little bit
more specific purpose it's part of
organizational design and that's
something that you supply for yourself
and your projects if you're doing a
thing you should probably probably know
why you're doing it if you're thinking
about growing your project or
organization probably you should go
through the process of discussing it and
writing it down right right those
purpose and values down with your core
team so you all understand them and
reread that together fairly regularly
this is going to help you keep that top
of mind as you make decisions and share
it outside of your core team maybe put
it on your website or your read me it
will help you attract other users and
collaborators who identify with your
project who maybe didn't understand it
in the first place but they connect with
you on the purpose level and that's
really important
governance is a more tangible idea than
purpose so as a result we tend to solve
problems using the realm of governance
over the realm of purpose governance
also means a lot of things so as an idea
can get really confusing but generally
speaking governance structures provide
the trellis upon which we can grow our
purpose and and those some of some of
those structures include corporate form
decision-making structures and decision
enforcement structures so what's
corporate form corporate form is any
group of persons treated as treated by
law as an a single entity having riots
or liabilities that are distinct from
the persons composing it and it's very
necessary for a lot of components in our
system including like the open source
foundations or standards bodies or
companies and maybe even one day your
project or your business corporate forms
things like C corpse LLC's they follow
different rules and they have different
rights depending also on the government
the government under which they were
incorporated and the government's under
which they operate and this starts to
make a difference as your project scales
if you think you might want to take your
project to a foundation or perhaps see
it through some sort of official
standardization process definitely take
a look at the corporate form of that
entity first because it might end up
making a difference decision-making
structures that's the who makes
decisions and how they do it in our open
source world this is generally all over
the map we have everything from like
that oh yeah whatever laws a fair kind
of decision making that happens to some
form of democratic process to you know
maybe a benevolent dictatorship and
foundations and standards bodies though
tend to operate a form of collaborative
governance and we're in all of those
stakeholders are collectively empowered
to make a decision through consensus and
or as is the case with equi
International that standardizes
and becca strip script to make
recommendations to an appointed final
decision body who does not substantially
change consensus recommendations from
the group they are judicious and nature
keep in mind that how you make decisions
for your project will change over time
depending largely on the stakeholders
you have and also what those
stakeholders value as those people
change the values are going to change
and that's ok if you think you'll move
forward towards the nonprofit or
standards track with your project and
then plan now for your transition to a
collaborative decision making a model
because that's actually along and and
you know can be a tricky Road no matter
how you make them degens don't really
mean anything unless you have some means
to enforce them and that though and
those means are actually useful there
are proactive decision enforcement
structures like testing suites and code
review protocols and things like that
and they help reinforce the decision and
mitigate risk before something happens
there are also reactive decision
enforcement structures that reinforce
decision at decisions after exposure has
already occurred so after something has
happened and these are things like clas
or codes of conduct you'll need to
consider your use of both forms
depending on the risks you think you
might be exposed to and if you think a
risk is really high you're probably
going to want to use more substantial
forms of both in order to mitigate it
successful systems can be attributed to
the skill we exercise and designing them
which is all that governance stuff we
were just talking about and making those
right government of choices in the first
place and also to the quality of the
operations of that system so here are a
few principles for us to consider as you
think about the operation of your human
system the first is simplicity as we
covered previous
complexity is not viral problems of
process and communication multiplied
with each successive stage of complexity
that you add so when operating your
organization and i like to say don't
play chess when you can play checkers be
precise with your definitions and tasks
people like that and don't try to build
a system or set policies and things like
that that solve a hundred percent of
your problems up front but rather
optimize your organization for one that
throws good errors over one that throws
bad errors the second is flexibility
organizations should have structure but
not be entirely rigid your organization
should let people in it make adjustments
based on new information from how
they're operating it that doesn't mean
that you're letting them like totally
change the goals or objectives here but
rather letting them change how they're
approaching that goal or objective based
on the new data that they have and
remember that there are also many
motivations for change why they might be
making a change in approach and you may
be tempted to only allow those changes
that align with your own motivations but
organizations are not personal things
and they're going to operate at times
with different motivations from yours
that's also a okay that's actually good
the third principle here is reliability
err I'm sorry yep reliability any system
is actually no more reliable than its
weakest component and reliability is
maintaining consistency in your
operations and also in your output of
both the human sort and the technical
sort it essentially means that it there
should be no surprises for people in an
organization or for the people who rely
on it reliability is also as important
for organizational growth as in as
innovation and software development
there can be some tension between
reliability and
vation in the system so you're going to
want to plan upfront for how you think
about balancing that in your
organization and as you would on your
project how you think about balancing
the stability and balancing the growth
our fourth principle which is probably
one of the most important is
acceptability any organization no matter
how well-designed it is is not going to
function properly unless it is accepted
by the people who operate it if
participants don't believe that the
organizational system is going to
benefit them if they are opposed to it
if they are pressured into using it or
if they think it's generally a bad
system and it's not going to work as
things and as you intended and two
things are going to happen either it's
going to be modified gradually over time
by the people who are using it which is
you know good but you know slow and
arduous or it will be used overall
ineffectively and ultimately fail so
make sure you're getting clear buy-in
from others in your organization and pay
close attention to resistance any
resistance that you feel that
organizational resistance and push back
is a human error message pay attention
to it if anything I've said today sounds
familiar it's probably because there is
a lot of similar thinking when it comes
to designing systems for software and
designing systems for people in both
forms of system architecture simplicity
reliability and flexibility are
frequently at tension with one another
and the general belief is that you
really can only have two of the three at
any given point and if you've happened
to figure out how to get all three in
your system I would really like to talk
to you in either case remember that
organizational design is the means and
not the end it's the framework through
which we will try and live our core
values and qualities and not how we try
and measure our success no matter what
stage you're at in your project it's
really never too early to think about
organizational design speaking of which
I think we can organize ourselves for a
better open web community and that we
can and should start doing that right
now because changes outside of our
control are impacting us there's a lot
of external and environmental and market
changes going on that we can't really
control things like big projects merging
we have a lot of new software
foundation's forming and old ones are
changing as well and companies are
investing is never before in open source
software all this means that there's a
lot of interest attention and money
being paid to how organizations interact
intersect and engage with open source
projects and we need to be able to
communicate and we have for our
community to these companies I chose to
speak today because I'm often asked how
we do things at boku those specifics
don't necessarily apply to everyone here
so I chose to bring you all a framework
we use to make those decisions I think
rising tide lifts all boats and I
believe that we can help each other more
efficiently and reliably using the tools
of organizational design i'm jory person
thank you very much for listening to me
today if I can help you in any way and
please hit me up on Twitter or github or
RC
you